so we will um learn a little bit about
how the aachar project is changing
pandas and dusk for the better
hopefully um the introduction about me
we can keep this brief um Tamara already
mentioned all the important things I'm I
work at coil where we deploy dusk for
our customers and my main responsibility
is improving Dusk and pandas so that's
nice to be able to work on open source
um almost full-time
um this talk will inter leave a little
bit pandas and dusk um pandas I guess
almost all of you will know what it is
um it's a python data analysis Library
that's used all over the world um but
it's a mostly single core so as soon as
you want to scale to huge data sets um
pandas won't be the best tool for the
job and that's where
dusk but more specifically um dusk data
frames come
in dusk at its core is a general purpose
like library for parallelized and
distributed computing in Python and one
of its strengths is that it integrates
with all the pi dat libraries among
those pandas DK py learn XG boost optuna
like most of the P data libraries have
some kind of dusk integration today we
will focus mostly on dusk data frames
which is depend
integration
um we will talk about a bunch of
different things um pandas started
moving more towards Apache arrow for
certain parts of the
API a couple of years ago um and this
resulted in a number of features that
are very helpful for like usability
performance and memory consumption
um users can now create Arrow back data
frames that means that the data frame is
completely backed by Apache Arrow
instead of
numpy um or use Arrow strings which is
for pandas the biggest strength of Arrow
at the moment um they are just way more
efficient than what pandas used in the
past to represent string
colors um then we have copy and right
this is a new feature that will be
enabled by default um relatively early
next year
um dask built a new Shuffle algorithm
which is used to send data over the
network um that is heavily based on a
pachy
arrow and we are currently that's my
main responsibility at the moment
building a cury Optimizer for dask data
frames so that it can make your queries
more efficient for
you um we will start with a quick demo
um just to get an impression how dask
behaved like eight to nine months ago
um I'm running a query here that's
heavily merge based merges are very
expensive in a distributed system and it
also does a bunch of group eyes these
are both things that dask historically
wasn't very good at and we will now see
why um on the right you can see the dask
dashboard and the top right this is what
dask is currently executing for us for
those of you who don't know dask white
and red is a sign that something
seriously wrong with your
workflow as you can see we have a lot of
white a lot of red here um and we have
many many small dots um these are also a
a sign that your workflow isn't
structured
properly and this is just going on until
the workflow finishes and it uses
significantly more time than what would
be necessary if the backend
implementation would be more
successful um the talk is structured in
a way that we will go through a bunch of
features that um pandas and dusk added
that will help like improve this
workflow and then we will see an end
to-end comparison right at the end um
that will show side by side how much
faster dusk got since um these settings
were active like earlier this
year I won't wait till we are finished
here otherwise I'll run out of time in
the end it's that
[Music]
slow so we will mostly talk about um
strings missing values um in the first
in the first chapter strings and missing
Val um the earliest feature that came to
pandas that was um backed by Apache
arrow is an efficient string data type
implementation like I guess most of you
who have like data frames that are a
little bit bigger than tiny um have
noticed this that the Panda's default
string data type isn't very efficient so
this brought us huge
improvements um but also we gained
access to a huge number of different
data types um previously everything that
was like non-numeric um or pool
basically fell back to nump object and
now we get access to stuff like byes
decimals structs list data types and
like many many more um as you can see
the left side is um like the default LPI
back end you can see everything's
object although it looks the same the
same on the top um the right is with
arrow backing and what we can see here
is that every one of these columns has a
specific data type representation and
not everything stored into like
object this is very helpful for
performance and general usability of
these um data types if you want to have
anything that's like non-numeric or non
gole um and like one of the biggest
advantages of Arrow from a user point of
view if you want to do different things
with different libraries is that
interoperability is great um you can
switch zero copy from pandas to spar to
polars to dctb
um all these libraries out there that
are somehow um using the arrow memory
format I've talked a little bit about
strings
already um the big discrepancy between
nonp object and P arack strings is one
of the reasons why we will start
inferring strings as P arack by default
in pandas 3.0 pandas 3.0 is hopefully
will hopefully be released like um in Q2
um 2024 so it's not too far
away um this means that you would
typically had have like something like a
data frame with string columns would be
inferred as object which is very memory
intense and not very fast and you don't
have to change anything we will just
basically just flip a switch and then we
will infer this all of those as P Arrow
back
um this string data type is modeled
after nonp object so so the behavior
should be pretty similar to what you um
are used to with object data type but
memory footprint will be significantly
lower and it will hopefully also be a
lot faster but more important is the
memory um savings if you have bigger
data
frames um you can easily try this out
today um if you are run on pandas
version that's 2.1 or greater um we
added a new Option PD options um future
info string if you set this to true then
you will get the behavior that will be
the default in pandas 3.0 like today um
if you just set this line top of your um
program script
whatever um this also means that we
don't have to convert to object if you
read paret files for example that are
already backed by the arrow memory model
which is roughly 75 to 80% of the
runtime if you read in a paret file with
string columns at the
moment um the conversion not the actual
reading um dask made this jump a little
bit sooner
um pabc strings are already the default
in
dusk um and like it's a little bit
easier to profile stuff with d because
if you have hundreds of gigabytes of um
data on your cluster or on your huge
machine then computations will run a bit
longer and you can like look at what's
going on there what we've seen is that
it's roughly two to three times faster
for most stuff compared to an npire
object but for most task users
performance isn't that important
um stability is significantly more
important to them than actual
runtime and what aror strings help there
by a lot since they reduce the memory
usage by a drastic amount um this graph
here is like object data type had like
220 gbt per strings close to 100
gbt um so it's more than a 50% reduction
but the important thing is this data set
only had three string columns and 17
columns with numeric or categorical data
types so switching free columns from
object data type to PCT strings reduce
the memory already by 50% if you have
like 20 string columns then the this
Factor will be significantly bigger than
our small 50%
here it's on since July in dusk as I
said it's already on by default so if
you install a new dusk version then you
will just get this Behavior out of the
box the next part of the talk will be
about copy and right copy and right is a
feature that um will also be enabled by
default in pandas
3.0 and I like to call it more in the
sense of getting rid of the setting of
copy warning um this brought us a lot of
pain over the last like I don't know I
think eight years now um and I am
hopeful that no user will actually miss
it like I passed around and I couldn't
find anyone who actually liked it maybe
I didn't look hard enough enough but I
don't think
so um so I guess most pandas users will
no this um you have a data frame then
you filter this for a subset of your
Bros and then you update the subset with
lock or iock just modifying the data
frame in place and then you get this
nice warning setting with copy warning
which basically means that data frame
will not be updated only subset but I
don't think that most people care about
this so it's just very noisy it's a
false positive it really doesn't
matter so this created a lot of
confusion the setting with copy warning
dock page is actually one of the most
visited doc pages of the pandas
docs which was concerning that's why
we implemented copy and right
mostly copy and right is a relatively
simple
idea it won't ever be possible to update
two penders data frames at once with one
operation so in our previous example
copy and WR will guarantee that always
subset gets updated only every time no
matter how you create it um this year
triggered a copy but you could also like
create subset through um view mechanics
and then it would update both at once
all of this will be gone um so there
will never be a confusion if your
operation updated one or two or five
data
frames um which this provides a simpler
and more consistent ux this is at least
what we hoping for um so every operation
only updates the op object you're
currently operating on so you don't have
to keep in mind that there might be
another data frame like 10 lines below
uh above your current um line of code
that might get modified um this will
just never
happen um there's no confusion anymore
about copies and Views um everything
behaves as a copy um and so we can get
rid of the setting copy warning I am
really looking forward to that PR that
rips that
up and then there's a third thing that
is probably the most important thing for
users I guess um pandas utilizes
defensive copying very very
heavily across the API and all of this
will no longer be necessary because
there's no view anymore that you could
modify so we can just get rid of all
these defensive copies um we did a bit
of a like fake bench mark here um all of
these
methods like rename assign drop as type
reset index set index all of them
perform a defensive copy at the moment
and we as I said can rip that out with
um copy and right so without copy and
right the run time is 2.5 seconds the
data frame has like three million rows
so not too big but also not very small
and with copy and right we get this run
time down to 13.7
milliseconds um so roughly uh an
improvement of like I don't know Factor
200 um obviously this won't be true for
the average pandas workflow as soon as
you do a group ey or a merge then copy
and right won't be helpful anymore
because data most likely will need to be
copied anyway but as soon as as long as
you're doing reshaping operations that
don't change the length of your data
frame you will see a huge performance
Improvement and then if you go back to
group I you will be back to normal how
it behaves right
now um this is also something that you
can enable right now um we basically
finished the implementation in pandas
2.1 um so it's more or less in the state
that we will release it by default in
3.0 so there are no known hidden bucks
uh no known bucks left anymore to
address as as long at least as far as we
know there might be something that we
missed that's the Pan part now we will
look a little bit into how we made dusk
data frames like multiple orders of
magnitude TOS faster um the theme of
this part will be D data frame is fast
now and the things that contributed
mostly to this except Arrow strings what
we've already seen is a new Shuffle
algorithm and a query optimizing
optimization for DK data
fres the lad part is not on by default
yet but we will see how you can enable
this if you want to um in a little
bit dusk historically struggled badly
basically with shuffling um it strained
the schul it didn't utilize the cluster
very well it copied a lot of data from
one machine to another which is very
expensive in a distributed setting like
doing something that can operate on one
machine actually doesn't matter
performance- wise as soon as you need um
shuffling at some point in your
workflow so this was improved earlier
this year and we are still actively
working on improving it further but the
performance increase and stability
increase is already huge
um we implemented a new Shuffle method
um that's called P2P Shuffle
um the two most important features are
like better performance and less strain
on the schul um previously um the number
of tasks which is what task executes
grew exponentially um based on the size
of your
data and now it's just it just grows
linearly with the size of your data
which is a really really huge
Improvement for how dusk operates in the
back
end
um this is like a TK dashboard as we've
seen a little bit briefly
earlier on the left hand side we see a
task based Shuffle um we can see this is
the memory usage um blue is good Orange
Is Not Great and gray is very bad um we
can see that this is like heavily
straining memory usage as I said earlier
white is bad and red is bad and we have
a lot of this here and our cluster is
basically fully utilized memory wise
even though our workflow is not even
half
finished and this over here is like the
new P2P um Shuffle algorithm that's on
by default memory usage is very very low
um everything's blue here nothing's
really in an area of risk that it will
um uh hit some Threshold at some point
and there's basically no white here the
workflow a later is there's barely any
white um you have a little bit here but
that's really not a problem at
all
so the um conclusion of this is the new
Shuffle algorithm um is able to shuffle
at constant memory so there's no huge
increase if your data set is huge this
doesn't matter you can still process
this with like I don't know if you have
a 10 terab data set you can easily
process this with 500 gbt of memory if
you never have to hold the whole data
set in um in memory
we have run benchmarks of this with like
30 workers to process a 10 terab data
set that wouldn't have been possible
before that at
all as I said Shuffle data at constant
memory um this goes back to the
stability um thing that distributed dusk
users care about like we can Shuffle at
constant memory and we don't strain the
schedule as much these are huge
improvements performance is mostly an
afterthought in distributed
settings and it's on by default since
March um so if you have a new dusk
version again then um you will have this
by default you don't have to do anything
specifically
um I'm currently working on adding
logical query planning to dusk this is
the last sub point of of the
presentation um currently dask is just
doing whatever you want um and it
doesn't do anything with your query so
we have a paret file here might have
hundreds of colors colums and in the end
we care about one value what dusk will
do is will just execute as you give it
as you give it to it um so we will read
all columns then filter alls aggregate
all of them with some and then we will
select one single value it's a lot of
work for only one
number so what query optimization will
do for you is like it will take a look
at your query and figure out that this
is really not that intelligent what we
are doing here so it will restrict for
example in read paret The Columns to X
and ID so we only read The Columns that
we actually
need um a little bit of a smaller
Improvement is that we're still summing
ID and X even though we only need X so
what the C Optimizer will do in the next
step it will just push the X in front of
the sum um obviously this has way less
impact than the previous modification
but if you have more columns and comp
more complex filters or merges this is
still like relevant performance
wise and obviously you can do this by
hand but if you have like thousands of
columns and you need like I don't know
150 of them then writing all of them
down is not really what you want to do
this is where the actual power of query
optimization comes in also if you have
very complex queries the query Optimizer
will figure out which column selection
needs to be in what place and so on you
don't have to think about this
manually um it's just another optimized
method that reorders the cury however it
thinks it's best for
users and for the end user it doesn't
really matter um the API will mostly
stay the same it's just under the hood
that there is a new layer between um the
user provides a input query and the Das
um scheduler actually starts executing
stuff in between there we will reorder
the query um as much as poss uh as
necessary um why we why are we doing
this like dask exists for like nine
years now and we're only starting this
now historically dask Focus mostly on
the physical schedu that schedules stuff
on the cluster as efficient as possible
um it didn't bother much with reordering
what the user provided this is like the
huge difference between spark and dusk
the spark um schulle isn't that powerful
but they have a very powerful query
Optimizer and dusk is exactly the other
way around um like to close the gap from
a dusk point of view with spark um we
add this now um to dusk so that we have
a like very powerful Schuler and at
least enough quer optimization that we
can get like 90% of the way
there um benchmarks we've run so far
were very promising like
on larger scale we already outperformed
askk even though we are not spark even
though we are not um nearly finished yet
we will see how this looks in a couple
of
weeks then we have another demo that I
promised
earlier we have like two versions here
the same quer that we've seen before on
the left side is the old version we will
give that one a little bit of Head Start
and on the right side is the new version
with quer optimization and P2P
shuffl um the first thing that we can
see is that our right version is way
faster in telling the schul what to do
um while the left version is still like
thinking about what's um on the plate
now and like what you can see here is
barely any white a little bit of red
because we're do an aggregation at the
end this is necessary but that's it and
like our right side is already finished
um it was very very fast um we had a
very homogeneous like schula view while
the right side at the left side the old
version is still out there like um
hustling
along we basically can see what we have
seen previously like a lot of w a lot of
red I just restart this
one um while we here there is none of
this like no W everything is busy we
have way less number of tasks like our
biggest number of tasks is for
127 um this is because we can drop a lot
of unnecessary work in this query um
that we know that we don't actually need
well over here we have 62,000 like I can
probably run this 10 times until the
other one is finished um for the first
time um so everything that's like
optimizable is way a lot faster this is
like based on P2P improvements in the
shuffle algorithm but also on the query
Optimizer that just drops a lot of work
that's necessary here that's performs on
the left
side um so going back to the
presentation real
quick I have like a couple final words
basically um what can you do now like
we've seen a lot of improvements in
pandas and dusk um most of them are
already in a state that users can
benefit from them if they want um copy
and right can be turned on through
setting the copy and right flag to true
I will upload the slides to um Discord
later so that you can um you don't have
to um take a photo of the of the options
right now um you can also info enable
the info string option with pandas 2.1
or
later this should like reduce your
memory footprint by quite a lot and help
performance as well if that's something
that you care deeply about and have
strings in your
workflow and these are just two options
like two flags to set and that's it
basically and then for the query
optimize and askk everything else is
already on by default you can just
install dask Expressions that's the side
project that we're currently working on
um we started this week of integrating
this into dask um the main dask data
frame API but it will still take us a
little bit till we can turn this on by
default since um the API coverage isn't
complete
yet so that's it from my side then we
can move on to
questions
awesome thank you so Patrick for the
wonderful presentation we have a few
questions in the Q&A and also in the
chat the first one would you comment
down copy on write implications Beyond
eliminating the setting with copy
warning are there any impacts to Method
chaining um no not to Method Training
Method training will work as it did
before it's just that it will be a lot
faster hopefully depending on what
you're chaining the only thing is
Chained assignment um that won't work
anymore um this is something that um is
in our copy and right migration docs
that are in the panda stocks if you want
to read up on this more but apart from
that um if you don't rely on um
modifying two objects at once you should
mostly be good to
upgrade uh next question is there a way
to review how the optimizer change the
query before it's
executed by default no but you can call
optimize by yourself um just like um you
would call compute in askk and then do a
predy print is the API um is is the
method um that we use for that that will
print out the query the optimized query
for you you can also print out the
non-optimized query if you want to comp
both of them but if it's a deep query
that's not that helpful because it gets
a little bit
confusing awesome thanks would you mind
elaborating more on the historical
differences uh of spark desk with
respect to polers how is the scheduler
and the query Optimizer of polers
compared to desk and
Spark um like that's a good question um
do and Spark are both distributed
Frameworks that can operate on a single
machine that's debatable by spark though
or on huge clusters um while polars only
runs on a single machine um so if you
have a huge machine and um you can
process your stuff on that then polers
is probably a pretty good option um dusk
is still faster um in our benchmarks at
least but it's not a huge difference um
but as soon as you have to scale out
over more than one machine then um dask
or spark are the only options because
polars or also duct B they can't do that
like they only support executing on a
single note and generally The Dusk schul
is more powerful than the polar Schuler
simply because distributed scheduling is
a lot harder than scheduling stuff on a
single machine
um Does this answer the question roughly
uh we have one time for one more
question perhaps are there limitations
to desk expression
um that's a very good question um at the
moment we don't support the whole API
yet but this should change in like the
next let's say in early January we
should be there with full API
coverage um and if you're there like in
a couple of weeks then there won't be
any limitations compared to D data
frames at the moment we are hoping that
the ux is a lot better for users and
that it's also that it provides
obviously a performance Improvement
increases stability
um but we also are building in a few
nice ux features that will hopefully be
helpful for um dusk users